C’est normal que le deuil de ma cousine ne se soit pas fait correctement, elle est morte il y a deux ans, je me pose encore tellement de questions.
Comme quoi par exemple ?
Bah genre, est-ce qu'elle a souffert, est-ce qu'elle s'est vue mourir et ce que son corps est devenu, tu vois ?
Ah, ça, je peux te répondre.
Alors il faut juste que tu saches un truc, de toi à moi,
c'est qu'elle n'a pas eu un enterrement très classique.
- C'est-à-dire ?
- Bah on l’a enterré nous-même dans une forêt bretonne en fait.
Ah ! C’était ses dernières volontés ?
Ça j'en sais rien.
Non, en fait, c'est qu'on l'avait sorti du congélo, et du coup, on a un peu été pris de court.
Ok, écoute, je n’ai pas tous les éléments, donc je ne vais pas te juger.
Si tu veux, on peut voir tout ça ensemble, si ça t'aide à tourner la page.
Mouais !
Quand on se lance dans 8 ans d'étude pour apprendre à devenir archéologue, il n'est pas rare que l'entourage exprime un certain doute concernant l'utilité de ce métier.
On pourrait bien sûr leur répondre que l'étude des phénomènes sociétaux du passé permet de comprendre certaines erreurs fondamentales qui ont été faites par nos prédécesseurs,
afin d'éviter de les reproduire dans le présent.
Mais tout le monde sait très bien que les politiciens n'écoutent pas les archéologues !
Alors pour certains d'entre nous il a fallu trouver un sens concret à la pratique de l'archéologie.
Et ce sont les forces de l'ordre qui nous ont donné un moyen d'être “vraiment” utiles à nos contemporains.
Voyons ensemble comment des archéologues spécialisés dans la fouille des lieux funéraires
peuvent aider à résoudre des crimes, parfois mieux que les médecins légistes.
Depuis les années 80 en France, il existe une sous-discipline de l'archéologie
dévolue spécifiquement à la fouille des structures funéraires.
Ça s'appelle la thanato-archéologie.
Cette nouvelle discipline a été conceptualisée par le préhistorien Leroi-Gourhan
avant d’être déployée par l'équipe d'Henri Duday de l'université de Bordeaux.
Le professeur Duday est médecin et archéologue spécialisé dans le Néolithique.
Il fouille donc des structures bordéliques typiques de la période qu'on appelle des allées couvertes.
Ce sont des sépultures géantes dans lesquelles on dépose des centaines de morts sur plusieurs générations.
Comme l'occupation de la structure se fait sur plusieurs décennies, des squelettes sont bougés,
intentionnellement ou accidentellement, et les gens viennent même récupérer des bouts de corps qu'ils sortent de la structure pour des raisons obscures.
Difficile donc de restituer les différentes étapes de l'utilisation du tombeau.
Pour y voir clair dans cet amas d'ossements, Duday décide alors de faire appel à ses connaissances en anatomie humaine et en médecine légale.
Il s'aperçoit vite des potentialités extraordinaires de cette interdisciplinarité et crée alors l’“archéo-anthropologie de terrain”
ou thanato-archéologie.
Les principes de la thanato-archéologie sont simples mais efficaces.
Tout d'abord, cette discipline exige d'adapter les méthodes de fouilles des structures funéraires
afin de ne pas bouger le moindre ossement du squelette.
On oublie donc la pioche et la pelle et on s'arme d'une petite truelle, d'outils de dentiste, de pinceaux et d’aspirateurs
pour évacuer les sédiments qui seront ensuite tamisés pour récupérer les plus fins indices.
Une fois le squelette enlevé de sa gangue de terre, on le photographie sous toutes les coutures.
On ajoute un quadrillage pour pouvoir relever la position des objets dans l'espace de manière très précise sur deux axes : abscisses et ordonnées.
On procède alors à un relevé millimétrique sous forme de dessin pour conserver en mémoire l'emplacement de chaque ossements.
Pour connaître la disposition des os et des objets dans leur volume, on mesure également l'altimétrie grâce à des instruments utilisés par les maçons et les topographes :
les niveaux de chantier.
Pourquoi une telle minutie dans le relevé des informations ?
Tout simplement parce qu'un os qui bouge de quelques millimètres par rapport à son emplacement anatomique logique,
ça raconte beaucoup de choses !
Quand le corps se décompose, les chairs, puis les tendons disparaissent.
Les os du squelette se désolidarisent alors les uns des autres et cette dislocation a lieu dans un ordre bien précis en fonction des conditions environnementales.
Vous savez donc que l'os hyoïde (celui qui flotte dans votre gorge)
sera l'un des premiers à se faire la malle.
Mais que les deux premières vertèbres cervicales prendront tout leur temps pour se déconnecter du crâne.
En observant précisément quel os a bougé et quel os est resté en place malgré la décomposition,
vous pourrez connaître les conditions de l'ensevelissement et répondre à des question essentielles, telles que :
Quel était l'état de décomposition du corps au moment de son inhumation ?
Est-ce que la fosse était remplie de sédiments... ou pas ?
Dans un espace colmaté par du sédiment, les déplacements seront minimes alors que dans un espace vide, ça peut s'éparpiller partout.
Du coup, si l’espace est vide mais que les ossements restent relativement disciplinés cela signifiera que le squelette était protégé,
comme lorsqu’il est mis dans un cercueil ou… une bâche.
Vous pouvez aussi savoir si des interventions ont été faites sur le corps après cette première cette inhumation ?
Une violation de sépulture pour commettre un vol d'objet ça fait des dégâts reconnaissables
que les archéologues peuvent replacer dans la chronologie générale des événements.
Grâce à un savoir empirique acquis après des heures de contact très sensuel avec la terre,
les spécialistes sont également capables de déterminer les limites précises de la fosse qui accueille le corps.
La texture du sol change en effet à chaque creusement de celui-ci et ces variations parfois infimes
se ressentent sous la truelle de l'archéologue expérimenté.
Grâce à cette discipline, les archéothanatologues peuvent donc tirer le maximum d'informations des sépultures anciennes.
Leur forme, leur durée d'exploitation, leur méthode de rebouchage, etc.
À tel point que ces avancées extraordinaires ont été adoptées partout dans le monde par les archéologues en l'espace de seulement 1 décennie.
Un savoir-faire qui nous vaut encore de recevoir les meilleurs étudiants internationaux dans le laboratoire PACEA de Bordeaux et de Paris 1.
Et qui nous permet aussi d'élucider des affaires criminelles aux côtés des meilleurs flics !
S'il ne reste pas de chair, mais qu'il reste des os :
on est là pour vous.
Or, chaque année en France, on retrouve entre 200 et 400 corps, dont la plupart sont à l’état de squelette.
Ça nous fait du boulot.
Lors d'actes criminels, il n'est pas rare que les meurtriers ou leurs complices essayent de cramer le corps pour faire disparaître les preuves.
Mais c'est un mauvais calcul.
L'archéologue funéraire est aussi formé à l'analyse des restes humains calcinés
et sera capable d'analyser ce que le corps a subi en détails
même si celui-ci a été passé au feu.
En fait, le plus simple pour faire disparaître un corps c'est de s'y connaître en géologie et en chimie des sols…
Alors, si tu veux savoir où enterrer un cadavre, le mieux si tu veux dissoudre le squelette, c'est de l'enterrer dans un sol acide.
Parce qu'en fait nos os sont principalement constitués de carbonates de calcium qui sont alcalins, et si tu veux les dissoudre, il faut mettre de l'acide dessus.
Donc, ça peut être aussi bien du jus de citron, du vinaigre,
très très concentré, ou sinon il faut que tu aies beaucoup de temps devant toi.
D'ailleurs, petite anecdote, c'est comme ça qu'on reconnait le calcaire sur le terrain, tu te balades avec une petite fiole d'acide chlorhydrique,
si tu mets de l'acide dessus et que ça bulle, c'est bon c'est du calcaire.
Pour en revenir au sol, il te faut un sol acide pour pouvoir dissoudre les eaux,
tu ne vas pas t'amuser à creuser des trous partout et mettre des bandelettes pH pour savoir si c'est acide ou pas.
En fait, tu as des indices que tu peux trouver sur le terrain.
Tu peux t'intéresser à la roche mère, c'est la roche qui est sous le sol, si cette roche est siliceuse
donc si ce n'est pas du calcaire ou plus du schiste ou du granit,
à ce moment-là, tu as plus de chance que ton sol soit acide.
Et sinon, tu peux t'intéresser à la végétation.
C'est vachement plus pratique quand même.
Parce qu'en fait, il y a très peu de plantes qui supportent l'acidité du sol, c'est ce qu'on appelle des plantes acidophiles.
Ce n'est pas qu'elles aiment l'acidité, c'est juste qu'elles la supportent mieux que les autres.
Et donc, ce qui est marrant aussi, c'est que ces plantes-là vont à leur tour acidifier le sol, c'est un peu une boucle rigolote.
Donc, parmi ces plantes-là, il y a le lierre, la myrtille, la fougère, les conifères en général.
Et donc, si tu as ces plantes-là au-dessus,
tu peux avoir des chances d'avoir des sols acides, et notamment le podzol qui est mon sol préféré,
c'est complètement à cause de son nom.
En fait, le podzol, c'est ce qu'on trouve par exemple sous la taïga en Russie, et c'est un sol qui est ultra acide et donc très peu fertile en général.
Dedans, on trouve ce qu'on appelle un horizon, une couche constituée de sable siliceux la plupart du temps.
Sinon, tu peux aussi miser sur une tourbière acide,
du genre avec des bruyères dessus, des trucs comme ça, parce que ça peut bien dissoudre le corps,
et puis je trouve ça assez cinématographique d'enterrer quelqu'un dans une tourbière, je ne sais pas ce que tu en penses.
Voilà, est-ce que ça répond à ta question du coup ?
Depuis quelques années, des archéologues funéraires ont été intégrés à l'IRCGN,
l'institut de Recherche Criminelle de la Gendarmerie Nationale pour aider à résoudre des affaires criminelles.
Ils sont plus précisément affiliés au département d'anthropologie hématomorphologie,
qui a un logo vraiment rock n' roll cela dit au passage.
Le champ d'action de l'archéologue auprès des gendarmes est assez vaste.
D’abord, en cas de découverte d'ossements épars, ils peuvent éclairer les enquêteurs sur l'identité du défunt
et sur la nature des lésions sur les os, en utilisant les méthodes de l'anthropologie biologique.
Évidemment, ça se fait en collaboration avec les légistes,
mais on ne va pas se mentir, les légistes sont davantage formés à l'analyse des tissus mous.
Et pour résoudre un meurtre, on n’est jamais trop nombreux à cogiter,
alors les retours d'expérience des archéologues qui manipulent des squelettes tous les jours sont les bienvenues.
Et puis parfois, on a une disparition, un suspect, un périmètre où on suspecte qu'un corps a été planqué mais.... pas de cadavre.
Or, retrouver le corps est indispensable pour restituer les faits et confondre les meurtriers.
Pour retrouver le lieu où le cadavre a été dissimulé, on peut utiliser des chiens renifleurs ou... des archéologues !
En effet nous savons reconnaître la présence de creusements et de structures maçonnées disparues en observant les variations de la végétation.
De manière générale, une fosse laissera un sol meuble, plus aéré,
qui accueillera volontiers une végétation abondante alors que les structures maçonnées privent les végétaux de racines profondes et entraînent donc leur raréfaction.
C'est comme ça que des archéologues découvrent des villes entières rien qu'en survolant la zone en avion !
Ceci dit, une fosse avec un corps humain dedans ne se comporte pas toujours comme une fosse normale.
Les jus de décomposition ont tendance à brûler les racines des herbes et des petites plantes,
ce qui peut provoquer des lacunes d'implantation chez certaines espèces fragiles.
Lorsque la topographie du terrain le permet,
on peut également trouver les fosses grâce à l'utilisation de géo-radars ou radars à pénétration de sol, des instruments utilisés régulièrement pour les prospections archéologiques
et dont l'utilisation est bien moins intuitive qu'il n'y paraît.
Un archéo est donc toujours le bienvenue pour les manipuler !
Une fois le lieu de la fosse identifié, il faut l'ouvrir pour retrouver le corps et les indices tout autour.
Mais attention, pas question d'y aller comme des sauvages comme ça a été fait sur l'affaire Émile Louis en 2004
avec une pelleteuse munie d’un godet à dents.
Ce carnage...
Les archéologues prêtent main forte mais en étant munis d'une pelleteuse à godet lisse pour enlever des couches fines et régulières de sédiment.
La conduite de ce type d'engin nécessite un permis mais surtout une grande expérience de manipulation.
Une fois le plus gros de la terre retirée, les archéologues funéraires passent à la fouilles fine et méthodique
qui leur permet de dégager le corps sans le bouger
mais aussi de retrouver tous les indices associés qui permettent de reconstituer toute une chaîne d'actions.
Chaque perturbation du sol est identifiée, chaque manipulation du corps ou du squelette est reconstituée afin de restituer l'état initial,
de remonter au temps zéro, c'est-à-dire à la scène de crime originelle.
J’ai appelé Monté, comme c’est lui qui a découvert le le corps et il a participé à l’enterrement tout ça…
Je me suis dit qu'il pourrait...
- Okay. Elle est morte de quoi ?
- De rire.
C'est ça. Mais c'est très bien, ça a vraiment l'air d'une mort naturelle comme ça.
- C'est une mort naturelle !
- Oui, ça ne me regarde pas.
Elle est restée combien de temps dans le salon ?
- 8 heures ?
- À peu près, oui.
Et c'était en hiver ?
Donc les insecte nécrophages n'ont pas eu le temps de se mettre dans le cadavre.
Parce que quand c'est le cas, les archéologues peuvent tamiser le sédiment autour du squelette, retrouver les petites pupes des insectes
et en déduire combien de temps le cadavre a été exposé à l'air libre et même la saison de la mort.
- C'est trop cool !
- Ouais hein ?
Donc tout de suite après, vous êtes allés l'enterrer dans la forêt ?
Alors non, après on l'a mise au congélo.
- Aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe.
- Fallait pas ?
Bah c'est-à-dire que la congélation ça fragilise la structure osseuse. Ça fait des dégâts identifiables au moins à l'échelle microscopique.
Or un cadavre qui passe par un congélateur, ça fait pas trop mort naturelle.
On n'y avait pas pensé à ça.
Rassurez-moi : vous ne l'avez pas mise au congélateur, puis sortie du congélateur et ce plusieurs fois de suite au moins ?
- Parce que c'est beaucoup plus grave ?
- Bah évidemment.
On recongèle jamais une viande qui a déjà été congelée, c'est un coup à choper la mort quand on la mange.
Après, on ne l’a pas fait plus de trois fois.
On t’a dit aussi que le chien en a bouffé un morceau ?
Les archéologues récoltent des indices permettant de remonter jusqu'à l'identité des meurtriers pendant la fouille.
Souvenez-vous, les archéologues sont des experts lorsqu'il s'agit de retrouver les bords de la fosse.
Or, sur les parois de la fosse se trouvent très souvent des traces de peinture
laissés par la pelle utilisée pour creuser le trou.
Celle-ci est alors soigneusement prélevée, analysée et il est possible de remonter à la pelle d’origine par comparaison avec celle des suspects,
surtout si elle a été achetée récemment ; les premiers coups dans le sol laisseront facilement de la peinture.
Un autre aspect fondamental en l'archéologie est exploité par la gendarmerie pour améliorer leurs connaissances.
Pour mieux cerner l’influence des micro-perturbations environnementales sur les conditions de décomposition des cadavres,
on utilise l’'expérimentation !
En maîtrisant tous les paramètres d'une inhumation on peut observer en détails
et sur le temps long les conséquences du milieu sur les charognes.
Évidemment, en France, on utilise des dépouilles animales.
Pour avoir de vrais cadavres humains, il faut aller outre-Atlantique…
Près du centre médical de l'Université du Tennessee,
il existe un terrain boisé d'environ un hectare clôturé par des barbelés.
À tout moment, on peut y trouver des dizaines de cadavres en train de pourrir en plein air.
Ou dans des coffres de voiture.
C'est de cet endroit, à éviter pour les pique-niques,
que provient une grande partie de nos connaissances récentes sur la décomposition humaine.
On l'appelle la ferme des corps.
En 1971, le Dr William Bass était souvent sollicité par la police pour des affaires de meurtre.
Mais faute d'installation appropriée, les connaissances de l'époque étaient encore très approximatives quand il fallait déterminer l'heure de la mort.
En tant que directeur du département d'anthropologie de l'université du Tenessee,
Bass décida de combler cette lacune en créant un complexe spécialement dédié à l'étude de la décomposition des cadavres.
C'est ainsi que la première ferme des corps vit le jour.
Parmi les corps en question, plus de 300 provenaient de personnes qui en avaient fait don à la science,
tandis que d'autres n'avaient simplement pas été réclamés au bureau du médecin légiste.
En étudiant sur eux les phases de décomposition et notamment le cycle des insectes,
Bass et ses étudiants ont permis de faire progresser la médecine légale,
et de résoudre de nombreux crimes.
Il existe aujourd'hui sept complexes de ce type aux Etats-Unis, régulièrement visités par les agents du FBI,
et parfois par des écrivains.
Dans les années 90, la romancière Patricia Cornwell visita la faculté d'anthropologie du Tennessee pour les besoins d'un de ses livres,
qu'elle intitula Body Farm.
Le surnom est resté.
Bref, la prochaine fois que vous voudrez planquer un corps en espérant vous en sortir,
n'oubliez qu'il ne faudra pas seulement esquiver la police, mais aussi les archéologues.
Alors, ce camping, c’était sympa ?
En vrai, si vous étiez venu avec moi, je me serais sentie un peu moins seule.
Ah ouais pourquoi, parce que tu étais la seule meuf ?
Non, mais disons que Fred et Lê étaient toujours ensemble.
Et ils parlaient soit de spatial, ou de jeux, ou de trucs bizarres.
Et Mehdi ?
Soit il nous observait de son côté,
soit il parlait allemand avec Lê.
C’était un peu excluant.
Attend mais ils parlaient en allemand, mais d'où ils parlent en allemand ?
Mehdi, il habite en Allemagne,
et Lê en Suisse, donc…
Non, d'accord, mais ils parlent français sur d'habitude, c'est super suspect de parler allemand là.
Je sais bien que c'est Arte et tout, mais quand même.
Vous savez quoi, il y a Monté qui parle allemand aussi.
Du coup, il va essayer de comprendre ce qu'ils mijotent,
et il va nous raconter, moi ça m'intrigue cette histoire, pas vous ?
Un peu, enfin, ça va quoi.
J'étais concentrée sur Patrick.
Si tu crois que c'est fini,
j'ai loupé ma bouche !
Y a Monté qui parle allemand aussi, je vais le mettre là-dessus, il va nous expliquer un peu ce qu'ils sont en train de fair...
Un peu, ça va quoi.
Elle est juste parfaite la petite mouche.